[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previous
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Doug Bachelor
Hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact a Virginia woman kayn
Phillips is lucky to be alive in 2021
one while studying in Bali Indonesia she
found a cute little golden octopus with
blue rings at the beach after catching
the creature she recorded a video of her
and her friends fondling the little
animal and passing it around before they
released it when she posted the video on
her Instagram account several stunned
people responded warning her that the
cute little seapod was the highly
venomous blue ringed octopus she looked
it up online and discovered the animal
is among the deadliest in the ocean with
enough Venom to kill more than 26 people
the bite of the little creature can kill
within minutes causing respiratory
arrest compounding her near-death
experience there is no antidote for the
Venom of the blue ringed octopus that's
a good reminder that some things might
appear cute and harmless but they can
still be deadly and you know it's
amazing Pastor Ross an octopus is so
quick at changing its colors in I think
a fraction like 1/3 of a second it can
completely change not only the color but
the texture of its skin it's probably
the most versatile of all the creatures
in the ocean and can you imagine the um
the horror of this young lady she cried
when she finally found out how close to
death she was passing it around with her
friends and all they had to do was anger
it and if it wanted to it could have bit
them and uh High mortality uh likelihood
if you get bit by that well you past you
think of dangerous animals you think of
a snake you think of those water snakes
you think of uh yeah I don't know sharks
and other animals but a little cute
octopus you don't think it's deadly it
seems kind of friendly and nice and you
know people pick it up and and yet it's
you mentioned before the program it's
got enough Venom in one of those uh one
little octopus that it could kill
multiple individuals 26 people they say
it's a thousand times more toxic than
arsenic wow so uh yeah very pois cute
but deadly and it reminds me of that
verse in the Bible where it says that U
Satan can appear as an angel of Light I
think when he appeared to Jesus in the
wilderness he didn't appear as a devil
he appeared as an angel Sent From Heaven
and uh so that he can deceive he's more
effective so you know we've got to be
careful because um there's a battle
going on between good and evil and Satan
he can use a combination of Truth and
error where God only uses Truth for our
friends who are watching I think we've
got a special brand new offer that is
right hot off the press that's right we
got a new magazine that amazing facts is
just finished it's called Cosmic
conflict if you've ever wondered about
did God create a devil or why is their
pain and suffering why does God allow
good people to suffer it's all contained
in the magazine the answers to these
important questions and as Pastor Doug
mentioned it's one of our newer
magazines very popular we don't always
offer this as a free offer but we are to
tonight so take advantage of that the
number to call for that is just simply
800 835
6747 or you can dial pound 250 say Bible
answers live and then ask for the
magazine Cosmic conflict we'll send it
to you if in the US or in Canada so
again the number is 800 835 6747 you can
ask for it all or just dial pound 250 on
your smartphone say Bible answers live
and we'll get it in the mail to you well
Pastor Doug before we go to the lines
let's start with a word of prayer dear
Father in heaven we thank you once again
for this opportunity to open up your
word and study and Lord we ask that
you'd be with us here in the studio and
the many who are listening across the
country and even in other places around
the world Lord lead us together into a
clearer and a full understanding of what
your word says Jesus said we shall know
the truth and the truth will set us free
so guide us in jesus' name we pray amen
amen all right well we're ready for our
first caller this evening Pastor Doug we
got Gary listening ing in Illinois Gary
you are on Bible aners
life thank you in Revelation 13 three
unclean spirits go out of the mouth of
the Dragon signs that lead the kings of
the earth to gather them to battle of
that great day of God Almighty uh to a
place in the Hebrew called Armageddon is
one of those signs 2 Corinthians
11:14 Satan appears as an angel of Light
if not when does Satan appear as an
angel of Light
okay good question a little correction I
think you're quoting Revelation 16 and I
think you said Revelation 13 this is the
verse that talks about Armageddon and
the when it says three unclean spirits
like frogs come out of the mouth of the
Beast the dragon of the false prophet to
go to the kings of the earth to deceive
them for a battle this is referencing a
story in the Old Testament where King
Saul was deceived by evil spirits when
he saw a witch before a a battle in
which he was slain and he actually
committed suicide but um so I think
there's Illusions to this happening
there in the uh Old Testament so in the
future it tells us that there's going to
be spiritualism that's going to be used
to deceive the leaders of the world into
embracing the teachings of the beast
power now is that when Satan
impersonates Christ I'd say yes he's
he's got to be part of that it's going
to be before the battle of Armageddon
because that's when it's going to do him
good it won't do him any good after the
battle and of course Paul writes that
the Devil Himself can be transformed
into an angel of Light so he appears as
a messenger from Heaven and the devil is
going to try and impersonate Christ and
maybe perform Miracles and signs and
wonders and gather together the world
for this final Conflict now of course
the Bible has good news it tells us that
at the end of time there's actually a
death decree that's not the good news a
death decree passed against God's
commandment keeping people but before it
can be enforced Jesus comes the second
time to rescue his people so those have
the Seal of God and they trusting in the
Lord they will be delivered yeah it's
like the book of Ester where there's a
death decree against all of God's people
and before it's enacted they're
delivered okay very good well thank you
Gary got another question coming from
The Book of Revelation Stephen in
Florida Stephen welcome to Bible answers
live hello how are you doing doing
wonderful and your question
tonight I have a question on the 144,000
and who they are and how me and my twin
brother can be there all right uh the
144,000 is found in Revelation 7 and in
Revelation 14 and as always one of the
keys to understanding Revelation is
having a familiarity with the Old
Testament and in the Old Testament
Solomon and David divided both their
armies and their priests in divisions of
24 and 12 and then of course Jesus had
12 Apostles 144,000 is 12 * 12,000 so in
the last days in the same way that
Christ had 12 Apostles it says the
144,000 follow the lamb wherever he goes
when Jesus came the first time 12
Apostles followed him wherever he went
Jesus told the twel apostles to go to
the lost sheep of the House of Israel at
his first coming before his second
coming he's going to have 12 time 12,000
laders that will be doing a special work
of proclamation just just like the
apostles the apostles were not the only
ones that were Spirit-filled at
Pentecost and saved uh just like the
144,000 are not the only ones that are
saved but they've got a special Mission
globally to prepare the world for the
second coming and if you and your
brother follow the lamb wherever he goes
you can be one of them and you know we
have a book that we'll be happy to send
you Steve or anyone wanting to learn
more about the 144,000 and it's called
who will sing the song 144,000 and we'll
send it to you for free all you have to
do is call the number 8800
83567 47 or dial pound 250 ask for the
book on the 144,000 we'll get in the
mail and send it to you if you're in the
US or in Canada if you're outside of
North America just go to our website
just amazingfacts.org you'll be able to
read the book online at the Free Library
thanks for your call Stephen we've got
Anthony listening in New York Anthony
welcome to the
program hello good evening pastors
evening thank you for calling
yes I actually have several questions or
uh on this kind of on the same verses
but my one question is um uh Revelation
19 verse 20 uh well 19 and 20 uh depicts
um situation where the Beast tries to
make war against uh Christ who sits on
the White Horse um in verse 20 it says
and the Beast was taken and with him the
false prophet that wrought Miracles
before him with which he deceived them
that ha received the mark of the beast
and them that worship worshiped His
Image these both were cast alive into a
lake of fire burning with Brimstone now
I've always heard and learned that the
Beast and the false prophet are systems
or they represent systems so what I like
to know is practically speaking if the
Lake of Fire which we believe is literal
um be uh before the Millennium uh how do
how do systems get cast into the Lake of
Fire well I'll do my best to explain
that uh in the Bible it talks about the
devil was cast into the Lake of Fire but
then it also says and his Angel so the
devil represents evil and the
opposition he has a system and he's got
followers underneath him not only is the
devil and his angels thrown in the Lake
of Fire you read where Jesus said that
um the goats are going to be cast into
the Lake of Fire that was prepared to
the devil and his angels so all the
wicked
so when it talks about the Beast it's
talking about any leadership of the
Beast and all the followers along with
it so they share the Fate when Queen
athaliah was destroyed in the Old
Testament it says and all that follow
her so um I think it's just the Beast is
you talking about the figure head and
there may be a physical Figure Head of
the beast power and the false prophet
but it's talking about them and their
followers that that would be the system
and if you look at the U the prophetic
picture both in books of Daniel in
Revelation you have for example in
Daniel you have different beasts that
represent kingdoms or political Powers
which are conquered by another kingdom
so that Kingdom would have a king a
leader but also the citizens of that
Kingdom so at the end of time there is a
counterfeit system of worship but it
also involves specific individuals who
are leading that counterfeit system of
worship right so that's all going to
come to an end as we find it described
here in Revelation chapter
19 thank you Anthony
we've got Britney listening in
California Britney welcome to the
program yeah I was wondering for the for
the actual you know saved and believing
Christian does it really matter if we
study the original Hebrew and Greek text
like the original Hebrew is it fine to
just stick with the
translation yeah you know um I'd say
that most most people that are going to
be in the Kingdom probably did not speak
speak the original languages so it's
certainly not a requirement for
salvation you know for some people uh
they are given gifts where they're
they're more uh analytical and they they
you know the Lord has raised up people
that are professors and teachers that go
deeper and I like to get into the
meaning of the word in the original it's
very easy now with computer programs I
can click right here on my computer
program and it will not only tell me the
meaning of the word in the original
language it'll pronounce it for me so
there's some great great tools today
that even a lay it if you if you're
reading through the Bible read through
and enjoy it but sometimes if there's a
word that piques your curiosity you can
easily look up that word on the internet
and say what's the original Greek for
that or the Hebrew and you can expand
you know the Bible says study to show
yourself approved it's it's nice but
it's not required that you can read a
Bible in another foreign language um I
would say for a new Christian don't
worry about reading it in the original
languages until you've read the whole
Bible you're acquainted with the
teachings pretty well because uh you not
only want to go deep you want to go wide
you want to make sure you get the scope
of the Bible story before you start
zeroing in on one chapter in the
original verses all right we got junith
listening in Nevada junith welcome to
Bible answers
live hello hello blessed evening to both
of you can you hear me
well yes okay yes the uh G of my uh
question is uh or is related to verses
uh Matthew
7:21 James 2:10 uh Revelation
149 and Mark chapter 2 uh verse
228 this is what did what or what does
Jesus really mean when uh he says depart
from me uh for I do not know you you are
Lawless is this the uh the
interpretation of the Mark of the 666
Beast I appreciate your um further
explanation yeah well the uh passage
there in both U Matthew and in James uh
the emphasis is on those that know the
Lord that are listening to his word he
wants us to not only be hearers but
doers of his word now certainly the
people that receive the mark of the
beast in the end days they're not
obeying the Commandments and doing his
word but I want to limit those verses to
to that time in history it's at any time
in history the message of Jesus and the
message of James and the others you
mentioned is basically saying uh God
wants us to not just be hearing but he
wants us to be doing so I said it's not
everyone that says Lord Lord but he that
does the will of my Father in heaven and
in James it says it's not those who uh
just look at the mirror but they are
seeing the word they hear the word and
they walk in the word and you know we do
have a study guide that talks about the
mark of the beast yes Revelation talks
about this beast power and he has a mark
and we'll be happy to send you a study
guide that tells you more it's a it's a
deep study an important study just call
and ask for the study guide It's called
The Mark of the Beast the number to call
is 800 835 6747 or again you can dial
pound 250 and say I want the amazing
facts uh study guide called the mark of
the beast and we'll get in the mail and
send it to you we've got James listening
in Tennessee James welcome to the
program thank you very much thank you is
144,000 is that
number uh compared to Noah's time when
there were only eight people saved is
that because the population is so much
larger now at this time of the history
of the world well there it's hard to say
exactly what the population was at the
time of the flood uh I think many people
believe that it was probably much bigger
than you might expect when you look at
the life expectancy
uh the people that were living before
Noah they were living centuries and
ostensibly they were procreating God
said be fruitful and multiply they're
very healthy and in virility and they
may have had very big families and you
do the math and there could have been a
billion people in the world back then uh
so we don't know it's it's hard to to
guess but um in the last days when it
says that there's 144,000 we don't
believe they are the only ones saved you
know right now they're are approximately
8 billion people in the world and I did
it on a calculator one time and I think
if only 144,000 people out of 8 billion
are saved that means your chances are
about one in
50,000 which could be discouraging it's
you know it's better than the lottery
but it's it's still not great but I
don't think the 144,000 are the only
ones that are saved I think when Jesus
comes he's not coming for eight or 10
people and it's going to look like a
failure I think he's going to have um a
a great
trophy uh of people that have trusted
him so um will it be the minority yes
it'll be smaller it's Broad Road is the
one to destruction uh the narrow gate
and few that find it is the one to life
because few are looking for it but you
may also enjoy the book on the 144,000
yeah all you have to do is just call and
ask for it the number to call is 8835
6747 ask for the book on the 144,000
we'll send it to you you know Pastor
also think that perhaps God waited until
the last moment when there was just
eight righteous people left at the time
of Noah in his Mercy wanted to give
people as much time as possible and as
you mentioned there probably were others
that were saved just prior to the flood
they might have died yeah some great
Patriarchs of the Old Testament and
their influence but at the time of the
flood there were just eight righteous
people now according to Bible prophecy
before Jesus comes the gospel gets
preached to the world and it'll be more
than eight that receive the message but
but it's small in comparison to the
world population right okay well thanks
for your call we've got who do we have
we've got Anna listening in Oregon Anna
welcome to Bible answers
live hi
hi my question is from the ninth
commandment about not lying so I have um
a nurse friend who works at a retirement
home and we were talking about how the
doctors tell
the nurses to basically lie to the
dementia patients and the doctors tell
everyone to basically lie to them
because it upsets them too much so I was
wondering is that considered
lying well I yeah no I understand I
think what you're asking is you got a
patient and sometimes I might be asking
a question they've got enough uh
knowledge to uh comprehend but they're
struggling with dementia and their
prognosis may be bad and if you tell
them that they get very stressed and it
makes things worse and so you try and
put a positive spin on what you're
saying to them and that point you know
it might not even be truthful you know I
never think it's right to lie uh I think
sometimes like with children they might
be asking you questions about the birds
and the bees and they're too young for
you to explain everything to to them and
so you share things in a u in in a
gentle way but you never lie to them uh
you know I don't think you should tell
your kids that Santa Claus is the one
who's bringing the presence and and
deceive them in any way Jesus said to
the disciples there's many things I have
to say to you but you cannot bear them
now so even Christ knew that you truth
must be shared at a speed that people
can digest it and I think you know a
good doctor has ways of uh not dis not
uh disturbing a patient but not lying to
them I I can't ever think of a scenario
where God would say it's okay to lie
yeah very good you know it is a
challenge I I think with working with
dementia patients in particular yeah you
got to be tactful pray for wisdom uh you
might have to explain things in a very
simple childlike Manner and maybe
emphasize the positive part of it but uh
you want to be honest in all your
dealings yeah so pray for wisdom on that
next caller that we have is is Lily
listening from California Lilia oh Lilia
welcome Lila welcome to the
program oh thank you yes hi pastors my
name is Lyla Laya welcome
Laya thank you and I live in Fresno
California my question is um um is Jesus
fully divine
because um I Heard a pastor saying that
he's not fully Divine because he will be
he is always and will be always under
the command of God the Father um what
does that
mean well I don't know exactly what the
pastor was thinking and I don't want to
you know put words in his mouth but I'll
tell you what the Bible says is that
Jesus is fully Divine Divine meaning
holy he is God the son you don't get any
higher than God now there is God the
Father God the son and God the Holy
Spirit but all three of them are
co-eternal
self sustaining and have Jesus said he's
from Everlasting to
Everlasting and uh you know while Christ
became a human and he has ever
associated with humans he has not lost
his
divinity so um you know Jesus is the
word made flesh he's the Alpha and the
Omega the beginning and the end all
things that were made were made by him
and the Bible says in the beginning God
created the heavens and the Earth and
Jesus is God the son absolutely and of
course there's a whole study guide that
talks about the godhead and uh it's
called the Trinity is it biblical it's
one of our books yep I think the new
version is one God or three one God or
three okay I was wondering about that if
we change the name one God or three is
the the name of the book and just call
and ask for it you can dial pound 250 on
your smartphone or 800 uh 835
6747 and you ask for the book on the
Trinity called one God or three we'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks Glenn listening in Ohio Glenn
welcome to the
program thank you pastors for taking my
call
certainly many pastors realize that
folks leaving the altar of confessions
believe that they have been saved and
born again but not realizing the
tremendous responsibility they have of
enduring to the end so that they can be
saved can be born again by a
resurrection like he was so they can see
and enter the kingdom and also receive
the gift of the everlasting life all
eternally secure at this
time and the question comes out of out
of 1 John 1 John 5:18 says he who is G
or born of God does not sin some
translations go so far as to say it
cannot sin well I think we all agree
that there's only one that has met that
criteria and that puts the rest of us on
the other side of the Ledger for John
says in 18b but he who is begotten of
God keepeth himself that the evil one
touch him not and my question is that
what did John mean when he said
um keep himself that the evil one touch
him not and does first John
59 I'm sorry first John 1 19 have
anything to do with that thank you all
right thank you very much I appreciate
that Glen um you know Jesus prayed for
the apostles and he told Peter he says
Satan has desired to have you that he
might sift you as wheat but I prayed for
you that your faith fail not and then
Pastor Ross might find the other verse
for me but in Jesus intercessory prayer
I think it's in John chapter 17 he said
father keep them that that you have
given me so it's using the same phrase
from the same author John 17711 want to
read that for us yes it says now I'm no
longer in the world but these are on the
world and I come to you Holy Father uh
keep through your name Those whom you
have given to me that they may be one as
we are yeah so when Jesus is praying for
the apostles that they might be kept and
he meant being kept from Evil and kept
from falling or being lost and that same
keeping power uh you know the Lord makes
available still to those that are born
again so you're on the right track Glen
that uh Jesus he can keep us from the
evil one and the Bible says greater is
he that is in you than he that is in the
world so the Lord certainly can save us
and keep us listening friends you hear
the music that just marks that we're
halfway through our program The Best Is
Yet To Come don't go anywhere we're
going to be back you can still call in
with your Bible
[Music]
questions stay tuned Bible answers live
will return
[Music]
shortly find out what the critics are
raving about top Scholars and
theologians from around the country come
together to reveal the hidden history of
the Book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 25
minute Masterpiece brings to life the
Book of Revelation like never before
Revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore.com
do you feel as though your world is
spiraling out of control or perhaps new
life challenges are frightening you more
than they should are you sinking while
you're thinking excessive worry can
consume you eating you from the inside
out resulting in sickness insomnia and
paralyzing fear it can also damage
relationships ruin opportunities and yes
diminish your witness for the gospel
worry affects everybody differently but
it's all driven by fear so how can you
overcome a world full of reasons to be
anxious I'd like to recommend for you my
new book Finding peace in a world of
worry you'll discover a Lifeline to
Victory a place where you can cast your
cares upon Christ and experience a
Serenity that isn't subject to your
circumstances send a gift of any amount
to receive your copy of Pastor Doug's
new book Finding peace in a world of
worry call
[Music]
87723214807 World millions of
individuals in over 150 countries have
been blessed by the word of God amazing
facts has spawned new spheres of
influence in India Africa China and
Indonesia with each new country come
hundreds of translated booklets study
guides and video presentations produced
in each region for the people of that
region armed with these precious truths
gospel workers are empowered to spread
bright rays of light on every path they
travel please visit reach the world .
amazingfacts.org to learn more about
amazing facts International and how you
can participate in this exciting
soul-winning Ministry that website again
is reachthe world. amazingfacts.org
thank you for your
support every year 40,000 souls in North
America end their own lives suicide is a
terrible tragedy and while it's
difficult to talk about we need to face
it together as Christians that's why in
my new book choosing life I share the
biblical perspective about suicide
answering some difficult questions about
faith and salvation along the way and
offering practical tips that should help
and encourage others Jesus wants us to
choose an abundant life in
[Music]
him you're listening to Bible answers
live where every question answered
provides a clearer picture of God and
his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for get practical answers about
the good book for a better life
today this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between
7:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program call
800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835 674 47
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers
live welcome back listening friends we
are live with Bible answers live and if
you've tuned in this is a live
International interactive Bible study
you can not only listen on this radio
station but we're uh on well satellite
stations around the world we're on the
internet Facebook amazing facts Facebook
Doug Bachelor Facebook YouTube and you
can even text your friends now and say
tune in and send in a question to Bible
answers life my name is Doug bachor my
name is John Ross and we're going to go
back to the phone lines a number of
folks who are standing by with their
Bible question alen is listening in
North Carolina alen Welcome to the
program thank you Pastor for taking my
call my question is about when Jesus U
was first resurrected and Mary Magdalene
came across him and he said to Hero not
cling to me in John
2017 well in Matthew 289 the disciples
came across him and he had just risen
and they held him by his feet and there
was
no said no saying not to touch him in
that I was wondering why she was asked
not to touch him in particular good
question you're you're paying attention
um in the Gospel of John John is telling
about when Mary is the first to see him
before he has ascended to the father and
had his sacrifice declared sufficient
and Victorious then he comes back down
to earth the same afternoon and the rest
of the apostles see him and he says now
all hail so he tells Mary says I've not
yet ascended to the father but go to my
brethren and tell them I Ascend to my
God your God my father your father and
um so she runs to tell the others and
then there's an interval of time between
that and when he shows himself to the
disciples because he doesn't see to the
disciples until he's in the the room if
I'm not mistaken so it's not at the tomb
it's in the room when the the rest of
the let me see here backing up she went
so they went out quickly from the tomb
with fear and great joy and ran to his
disciples and as they went to tell his
disciples Jesus met them saying Rejoice
they came and held him by the feet yeah
so this is later when this
happens there an interval yeah very good
good observation all right next caller
that we have is Jerry listening in Texas
Jerry welcome to the program
good evening uh Salam Alum evening this
is Jerry from Texas and I have a uh
Bible question on Revelation 4:4 there
are a couple different scenarios that
different pastors attribute to uh one
Bible comment commenter says that the 24
Elders on the
throne that uh this one Bible
commentator that they were from the be
from unfallen world
and the other half of the equation some
of the pastors say it was some of the
Saints who were risen with Christ can I
have your guys take on it I think Pastor
Ross and I are on the same page that
these are likely representatives from
unfallen Worlds that uh it because you
read in job where it says there's a day
when the sons of God came to present
themselves before the Lord well that's
before the resurrection of Matthew 28
and so he had
uh some kind of uh Concourse with
leaders in heaven it's not in heaven
it's somewhere because Satan's not
allowed to go to heaven it say Satan
came among them so I think the probably
the 24 Elders in the same way on Earth
you know Solomon and David often had 12
or 24 judges around them that uh they're
modeling what happens in heaven where
God has uh leaders from unfallen Worlds
um
yeah and if you look at the context of
Revelation 4 and5 Revelation 4 you have
a description of the Heavenly throne
room and God is seated upon the throne
God the father he talks about the 24
Elders surrounding the throne Jesus does
not appear until chapter 5 and then he
appears Before the Throne as a lamb as
it had been slain so in chapter 4 You
got a picture of Heaven this is even
before the Ascension of Jesus and those
who were resurrected at the time of
Christ Resurrection well they ascended
up with Jesus when he ascended and they
were the 24 elders already prior to this
in heaven and of course Isaiah has an
interesting verse is the Old Testament
Isaiah 24:23 says the Lord shall rule
before his Elders gloriously so we even
have a reference to the elders in Isaiah
in the Old Testament and then as Pastor
Doug mentioned the sons of God or the
representatives of these unfallen worlds
so I think there's good evidence to
support the idea that there are these
representatives from these unfallen
worlds and the devil claimed to be the
representative of Earth but of course
now Jesus is our representative in
heaven so are these the UFOs the
government's hiding from us these
unfallen worlds they're going ask a
question we're not going to answer
investigation on that all right thank
you Jerry we got Mark in Hawaii Mark
welcome to the
program and thank you for taking my call
just had a quick question on Revelation
11 uh the interpretation I have heard is
that this Beast starts out um with the
attributes of the Lamb then at some
point it transitions to the attributes
of the Dragon but a simple reading of
the TR excuse me the text seems to
indicate that it's more like a dual
nature that it always had the horns like
a lamb and spake like a dragon is there
something in the translation from the
original text that would indicate it had
a changing nature rather than a dual
nature that's a good question and I I
don't want to pretend that I know on the
tip of my tongue what it's saying in the
original Greek there because I haven't
looked at that in a while my my thought
is that the way Revelation is written
Pastor Ross might have more on this the
thought is that the way Revelation is
written um things can happen in sequence
where you read it in one verse but the
space between the first part of the
verse and the second part of the verse
could be hundreds or thousands of years
so when it says it speaks two horns like
a lamb and many believe that this second
beast is representing the United States
of America that began with lambik
qualities foundation on the word wanting
to have a city on a hill freedom of you
know ultimately freedom of religion then
the two horns were a a country without a
king and a church without a pope so
there was freedom of of religion and
freedom of
citizenship and um but it ends up
speaking like a dragon in the end where
it uh turns from those things yeah and
if you look at the specifics there it
talks about speaking like a dragon and
we know a nation speaks by its laws so
even though it has these two lamb-like
principles as Pastor Doug mentioned
which sort of form the foundation of the
government of the United States the time
comes when it passes laws that actually
contradict the foundational principles
of religious freedom and uh personal
freedoms that we find so it's a
transition it begins like a lamb but it
makes laws at some point that reflect
more of the dragon that restricts
religious worship you know we do have a
study guide called the US in Bible
prophecy and it gets into the details of
this we'll be happy to send it to anyone
who calls and asks the number to call
for that is 800 835
6747 again you can just dial pound 250
with your smartphone say amazing facts
or Bible answers live and ask for that
study guide is called the usn Bible
prophecy in fact Pastor Ross I think we
also have a brand new magazine with a
similar title is it America American
prophecy I think prophecy yeah so we
don't want to confuse you but those of
you who may have already seen the lesson
you may check out the magazine and the
magazine I think is bigger and it's got
It's expanded it's a great read great
study so take advantage of that all
right next caller that we have is Thomas
listening in Oklahoma Thomas welcome to
the program I have a question for Exodus
353 and then say don't not lie as far
and any of you do
on the Sabbath
day but in my church then say we can do
a life Li fire in the Sabbath day but
this verse says otherwise yeah well of
course I believe what the Bible says now
when it says Kindle a fire that doesn't
mean you can't have a fire um in keep in
mind the children of Israel going
through the desert they didn't really
need a fire for heat and they didn't
need a fire for cooking
because um God told them says bake what
you're going to bake and boil what
you're going to boil on Friday he said
I'm going to give you twice as much mana
on Friday so you can rest kindling a
fire for us right now I mean if you turn
on your stove there's really no work or
labor involved kindling a fire is
different from having a fire if you
started a fire on Friday and you kept it
burning you're not kindling a fire
kindling a fire was often rubbing SS
together is pretty labor intensive in
Bible times and so um it's basically not
starting a fire um I I know I heard one
preacher say oh you can't drive to
church on on Sabbath because every time
your spark plug fires you're breaking
the Commandment well that's not what
Moses is talking about and you know
there's some people they take this way
too far and in Christ time in Jerusalem
they had fires in their dwellings to
stay warm on the Sabbath The Practice
was they'd start the fire uh the day
before so they didn't have to go through
the labor of kindling it and the
practicality of that is in the desert
there's not a whole lot of wood so to
gather wood for a fire especially if
you're going to do it on the Sabbath
that's a big job you'd have to go out
from the camp and gather what you could
and no that had to be done during the
week on the Sabbath was a day of rest
yeah and matter of fact Pastor Ross if
I'm not mistaken this uh command is
given in connection with an experience
where a man was caught Gathering wood
and they said what do we do with him mhm
so he said look you know you don't need
to gather wood and Kindle a fire on the
Sabbath it's kind of the two together
okay very good good question uh Lee in
Texas Lee welcome to the
program yes sir hi my my question is
that is the Pope the Antichrist because
he speaks for the papacy I know he's the
man of sin but does he change into the
Antichrist being that he he is speaking
for the papacy well now before I answer
that question I want to preface and say
all the Protestant reformers and listen
carefully not only Martin Luther John
Calvin John Wesley John
Knox uh George
Whitfield um Charles Wesley they all
said and what's the um wickliff MH
Kramer and many of them were Catholic
priests as they started they all said
the office of the pope is
Antichrist and what they meant was when
you start putting a man in the position
of God or saying that he is the Vicor
for Christ on Earth which is really the
work of the Holy Spirit they believe
that was Antichrist so when we say this
I just want folks to know so some folks
are shocked that's what Protestants
traditionally taught and we still
believe now there are don't
misunderstand listening friends there
are just wonderful Spirit-filled lovely
people in every Church including the
Catholic church but the the system uh
that evolved into the present day Roman
Catholic Church
is anti-christian in its teachings and
that was the what caused the whole
Protestant reformation and you know it's
interesting Pastor Doug the official
position of the Roman church or the
Catholic Church as far as the doctrines
go they haven't changed now of course
attitudes have changed towards
Catholicism and you find even
Protestants now reinterpreting some of
their original understanding of Prophecy
to kind of soften what they believe but
as far as the actual Catholic Church
they haven't changed their position and
their understanding of the role and the
significance the importance the
infallibility of the Roman Pon for the
pope so uh it is interesting when you
look at that history now there what
something I I think I found it just in
time folks might be shocked to know that
the first person or one of the earliest
people who said that the um Pope the
office of Pope was Antichrist was Pope
Gregory the Great and so you hear and he
live 540 to 604 he was last four of the
original doctors of the church he wrote
I confidently affirm that whoever calls
himself the universal bishop or desires
to be so-called in his pride is a
forerunner of antichrist that's an exact
quote from a pope so this is uh not a
new statement some people are shocked to
always hear it for the first time and
during during some of the history of the
Roman Church there were times when there
were conflicting popes claiming to be
call the other the saying the other was
Antichrist right all right well thank
you Lee you know we do have a study
guide that talks about this and it's
called who is the Antichrist and we'll
be happy to send it to anyone who calls
and ask the number is 800 835
6747 and uh you can just dial pound 250
on your smartphone say Bible aners live
ask for the study guide It's called who
is the Antichrist we've got Andrew
listening in Kansas Andrew welcome to
the program hello pastors hi thanks for
calling so my question is Angel who the
one that was in in the pillar the the
the pillar of cloud in the wilderness
and that night he was a pillar of fire
was that God the father was that God the
son well typically it is God the son of
the three members of the godhead it is
God the son who is the link or the
mediator between God the father and man
and if you read in 1 Corinthians chapter
10 Paul describing the Wilderness
experience he says Christ was The Rock
you know Christ is the bread Christ is
the water and so we believe that um it
is Christ you know God the son that was
in the wilderness the the word Angel
there just means messenger of course God
Jesus Is Not An Angel like a cherub or a
Sarah from Jesus's God the son but uses
the word the angel of the lord of the
messenger and you know another story
that connects that is Jesus said to um
Nathaniel he referred to the story of
Jacob when he saw the ladic coming down
from heaven he says uh after this you
shall see Angels ascending and
descending upon the son of man so the
latter that connected Earth and Heaven
Jesus likened to himself so he is the
intermediate Between Heaven and Earth
and again Jesus said no man has come
down from heaven ex or ascended up into
heaven and come down except he that has
come down from heaven meaning himself so
Jesus is the one that came down from
heaven and has connected Earth and
Heaven another good verse on that is
where it says the angel of the Lord met
with Joshua and he says take the shoes
off your
because this is Holy Ground and he
worships you only worship God you don't
worship an angel okay very good next
caller that we have is Steve in Oregon
Steve welcome to Bible an's
live yes um thank you for taking my call
um I'm calling in reference to um
chapter 10 in Daniel which it says that
Daniel had been in prayer for in like 21
days and the angel was delayed by the
prince of
Persia in his response to come to Daniel
and just who was the Prince of Persia
and how can one of God's angels be
delayed by three M three weeks yeah it's
well when it says the Prince of Persia
um keep in mind what you're dealing with
here is the spiritual Powers behind the
rulers There Are Spiritual battles that
we don't understand
uh you read in Revelation 12 Michael and
his angels fought with the dragon and
the dragon and his angels fought uh
there is some striving that goes on you
know even Paul said we do not wrestle
against flesh and blood but against
spiritual principalities and powers and
when Daniel was praying for the Persian
king to um now release God's people
according to the Prophecies of Jeremiah
that after 70 years they'd be allowed to
go home
the devil was influencing the Prince of
Persia and there was a battle going on
maybe between his advisers and it shows
that that Christ sometimes he pictured
as Michael he was striving with Satan
who is the prince of who is manipulating
the Prince of Persia you can also see
this in Ezekiel where it talks about the
devil and it talks about the king of
Tyrus and Isaiah talks about the king of
Babylon then we realize it's the devil
behind the king and you go to revelation
12 and it talks about the dragon wanting
to destroy the baby and we realize that
it was the devil working through the
Roman or King Herod so it's the devil
often working through these um powers
and that's what's happening here in
Daniel 10 there's a battle going on and
God has enforced the will of his people
he gives him the freedom to choose it's
an interesting story here the the prince
that's been referred to Israeli Cyrus
the king and he was prophesied by Isaiah
to be the one that would allow the Jews
to go back and start rebuilding the
temple in in Jerusalem and of course the
devil didn't want that and so he was
doing everything he can to try and get
Cyrus not to do it and yet on the other
hand you have Daniel who probably
pointed out to Cyrus here's a prophecy
150 years before you were born that
mentions You by name there was a real
controversy taking place would he allow
them to go and maybe that's what's
referred to here in the verse two yeah
and I think it's the same period of time
it says Daniel was praying during that
time so in answer to his prayers Michael
prevailed all right next caller that we
have is calling from Spain we got
emanuel's Spain listening from Spain
Emanuel welcome to the
program um thank you pastors good
evening good
evening my question for you um is If U a
church that get uh that gets certain
doctrines wrong can have the presence of
the holy spirit in it for example if
they get um dietary laws wrong or the
days in which they meant to keep the
Sabbath wrong can the Holy Spirit be in
that
Church
yes is a quick answer now what what I'm
saying is if if God spirit is only going
to work in and through a church that is
uh perfectly correct in every
Doctrine uh
than I can think a lot of times in
history when God's spirit has worked
through the church in spite of its
imperfections I think God's spirit was
working through the Protestant
Reformation but uh you know they didn't
have everything right uh they probably
didn't understand some of the laws of
the Bible about diet or even the Sabbath
but they were coming out of great
darkness and times like this it says in
what is it acts 17:30 at the times of
this ignorance God Winks at and the
apostles you know when Jesus breathed on
them and said receive the Holy Spirit
that's in John before his death and then
they even after the resurrection they
say Jesus will you now establish the
kingdom they didn't understand and uh
the nature of his kingdom completely but
he still gave them the Holy Spirit and
they continued to learn when he poured
out the Holy Spirit they didn't
understand the gospel was supposed to go
to the
Gentiles that that took a little
struggle so I I I do think that God's
spirit works best when we're fully
committed to follow the light that we
have and um I don't think God's spirit
restricts us for what we don't know it's
when we reject what we do know and I
think that's a good point Pastor Doug
you know if a church knowingly or openly
let's say a pastor a leader in the
church who knows the truth and yet they
turn away from the truth um then they
living open Defiance against God but if
folks don't know the truth or at least
an aspect of the truth and they're
living up to all the light or the
knowledge or understanding that they
have you know they're sincere then God
can kind of work through them but if you
know the truth and you turn away from it
and I think individually as members of
churches we want to make sure that the
church that we're a part of they living
up to all the truth that's been revealed
in the word of God as far as we can find
or as far as we know uh if we come to
conclusion that something's wrong in the
church they're not following the
biblical principles well then we need to
find a church that is actually close to
the word of God as close as possible you
know we do have a study guide or
actually it's a book talking about this
is called the search for the true church
how do we find a church that is
bible-based you'll be interested to uh
find out that the Bible tells us how to
do that just call and ask 800 835 5 6747
we'll send you a book called The search
for the true church uh dial pound 250 on
your smartphone and we'll send that out
to you next caller that we have let's
see we've got Sherry in Kentucky Sherry
welcome to Bible answers
life hi
hi um I have a question that's been
really bothering me um in the days when
we're later on during the tribulation
time when we're not able to buy or
sell um I'm I'm I'm debt-free right now
and I own my home but I have to pay my
taxes every year right what am I gonna
do am I gonna be without a
home well I wouldn't worry about that um
because I I think that you I've heard
some people say well I'm going to prepay
my taxes so they can't take my home away
during that time I think the when it
gets to the point where they're using
buying and selling to manipul at us it's
going to pinch us a lot sooner at the
food basket than home
taxes and so I I think that you know
we're going to probably be driven to
places where we need to you know maybe
grow some of our own food there there
will be trying times whether they're
going to say we're taking away your home
because you didn't pay your taxes or
something like that usually a person can
go two or three years without paying
their home taxes before they foreclose
on that I mean but who knows what kind
of laws you you look at what happened in
Nazi Germany to the Jews and they
basically threw all rights out the
window so it didn't matter whether they
paid their taxes or not so I'm not
trying to worry anyone I'm just saying
that when it gets rough like that
there's probably nothing we can do other
than making sure our faith is strong to
preserve us and don't forget that the
Bible does promised us that during that
time of trouble your bread and your
water will be sure so God will provide
for his people just as he did for the
Israelites with Mana in the wilderness
provided for Elijah during a famine that
was in the land God will take care of
his people and as Pastor Doug said I
think the most important preparation we
could do is hard preparation and then
the Holy Spirit can guide us when that
time comes amen all right thanks for
your call let's see we've got uh B
listening
B yes we got about a
minute hello pastors uh I have a
question here on Matthew chapter 17
where Elijah uh Elijah and Moses
appeared to him uh when he was at uh on
the mountain so my question is so I I
know that when somebody dies they don't
come back to us and talk to us but then
here we see Moses who had already died
in um Old Testament also appear to Jesus
here and
Elijah who might know that was taken to
heaven so I just want to know like what
does that affirm that we can talk to
people after they die they can still
come back to us and talk to us what does
this um mean yeah well let's do our best
to answer that just have a few minutes
but generally speaking of course we
shouldn't communicate with the dead or
try to Isaiah 8 tells us that that's a
sin um we know there's an exception most
of the Dead are sleeping but Moses and
Elijah are an exception Moses in
particular Elijah never died so we're
out of time for that don't go away
friends we're signing off for our
satellite listeners for all the rest of
you stay tuned we're going to do rapid
fire Bible questions in just about 30
seconds when we come
back thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California Hello friends and welcome
back to Bible answers live we want to
thank you for your email questions that
you've sent in and we're going to take
uh as many questions as we can in the
next few minutes if you have a Bible
question that You' like to email to us
just simply BL questions
amazingfacts.org and we'll try to answer
your uh question online Pastor here's
the first question uh Bicky is asking
what kind of stone did Moses use when
God commanded him to write the Ten
Commandments
again you know the Bible doesn't
specify um based on some visions of the
throne room of God and I think it's out
of Ezekiel talks about like a sapphire
stone and so some have wondered if it
was some kind of a blue sapphire stone
since blue is a color associated with
the law that children of isra were to
put borders of blue uh but it doesn't
specifically say that's kind of a
beautiful guess okay we don't know what
it was and we've got some Granite Ten
Commandments in our church someone made
for us they look very nice all right
another question that we have uh and
here's the question Wilma is asking is
the Nazi re regime's attempt to
exterminate the Jews found in Bible
prophecy well there there's a prophecy
in Deuteronomy 28 it's called The
Prophecy of the blessings and the
cursings and blessings were promised for
God's people in obedience cursings were
you know forecast cast in Disobedience
and so this is not just for the Jewish
people but for every believer everyone
that knows the Lord and so you know some
have wondered if you know the terrible
trials that came on the Jewish Nation
during the Nazi regime if that's
something that Moses was alluding to now
it is true that Moses foretold he says
your enemies will surround you they'll
besiege you um and that happened several
times in Bible History in the Old
Testament but does that reach Beyond to
you know
19439 or 41 in Nazi Germany
um some could speculate that but uh I
think there's a principle that for any
people when we turn away from the Lord
we're you know there's uh trouble and
curses that often come okay the next 30
seconds do we have to be perfect to go
to heaven oh yes but we get that
Perfection through Christ yeah Jesus
said that
you know he can transform us and make us
new creatures he gives us his
righteousness through justification and
then in sanctification he teaches us to
walk in a newness of life you can have
that experience friends we hope you tune
in tomorrow not tomorrow next week for
more Bible questions God willing we'll
be together then keep us on the air and
go to amazingfacts.org
Bible answers live honest and accur
answers to your Bible
questions